et ce procès décidément l'occasion de
revenir sur des événements historiques
36 ans après les faits la manifestation
du 17 octobre 61 été beaucoup évoqué une
manifestation violemment réprimée qui
avait causé la mort de 200 algériens à
l'époque maurice papon était préfète
police à paris et le climat était
particulièrement tendue dans la capitale
emmanuel gagné joseph tual
octobre 61 maurice papon préfet de
police de paris impose le couvre feu
pour protester contre cette mesure
d'exception le fln appelle à manifester
pacifiquement le 17 octobre trente mille
algériens et leurs familles se
rassemblent dans les rues de paris face
à eux dix mille hommes chargé de
disperser cette manifestation interdite
la répression policière sera sanglante
bilan officiel de morts 64 blessés et
des milliers d'interpellations hier à
l'audience maurice papon admettez que
des victimes sur dix fois plus
nombreuses aujourd'hui à la demande des
parties civiles jean luc einaudi
historien est venu témoigner à la barre
pour lui maurice papon serait bien le
responsable des violences policières
maurice papon pour prendre un seul
exemple il y a eu ce jour-là un certain
nombre de forces nouvelles qui ont
circulé sur les ondes de la police
faisant état de policiers qui venaient
d'être tués
art
des algériens qui étaient absolument
faux seins et bien le préfet de police
n'a pris aucune initiative pour démentir
ces fausses nouvelles et ont contribué à
exacerber la haine maurice papon affirme
qu'il n'a fait qu'obéir et d'après lui
les victimes du 17 octobre seraient des
dissidents assassiné par les commandos
du fln mais pour cet avocat du mouvement
nationaliste pendant la guerre d'algérie
maurice papon en 61 ce ne serait qu'une
répétition de l'histoire
on lui est imparti une mission bien
précise
cacher le fln
dans la région parisienne et il a mis en
place des méthodes qu'il avait
certainement dû utiliser durant
l'occupation
que s'est il exactement passé le 17
octobre 61 quelle est la responsabilité
de maurice papon dans la répression
policière pour tenter de répondre à ces
questions catherine trautmann ministre
de la culture vient d'annoncer qu'elle
demande dès l'ouverture des archives